what is going on everybody welcome to
part two of the cyber python 2077
series uh the universe is actively
conspiring against me to film this video
the camera continues to freeze i have a
neighbor that is determined that today
is the day
to sit in your driveway and just rev
your engine for
like 30 minutes so here we are on like
take
attempt number three i'm determined and
i'm going to take control of my destiny
by getting rid of the webcam nice
okay so uh where we left off we were
kind of walking and following that
yellow path just kind of as a
proof of concept and now what i'd like
to do is since that does work
is like figure out you know what are we
going to do um from here so
my proposal is that rather than
following the yellow path so those of
you who aren't familiar with
cyberpunk 2077 the yellow path leads
to main game objectives the quest line
that kind of thing
whereas uh the blue paths lead to these
like
police scanner events so with the police
scanner thing
all you do is you would follow the path
you get there there's some bad guys you
fight the bad guys
rinse and repeat so it seems like that's
probably a good starting point so i
think that's
where we will start so with that start
we have to make a change rather than
following the yellow path we're going to
follow the blue path
so um in line with kind of how i did the
last
video i think for the most part i'm
going to bring in the code kind of piece
by piece as we make it
so rather than um handwriting everything
and character by character i think it's
a little silly to
to do something like this that way so
if you like that or you want to see more
hand coding or something like that let
me know but i think this makes the most
sense
so um so yeah we're going to follow this
blue path i've conveniently set myself
up
to where we'll kind of walk this way and
then cross that crosswalk which often
leads to running into a car
and that's kind of one of our other
problems is often you'll get stuck on
stuff and we need some way to get off of
those things so we're going to go over
how we're going to do that okay so
first thing is to come over to sublime
text
hello and begin making our changes so i
think also i'll try to put this on
github if
if i forget to put it up or put a link
and one of you really wants it just
post a comment or something like that
remind me and i'll put it up on github
so um so to start we want that blue path
rather than the yellow path but there's
going to be plenty of times where we
want that yellow path
so i propose that we save them both we
just need kind of a way to start
collecting all of these
color filters so my method for doing
this is just to save them as constants
so it's just going to be tuples of the
lower
and then upper values so then the only
change that we need to make
is like in the pathing function rather
than just taking in minimap
it's also going to take in a color this
will be that tuple
and then essentially it just becomes
lower upper
and then we'll unpack that color tuple
that gets passed
so then all we need to do is come down
to where we call the pathing
here and then we'll go ahead and pass
color equals and in this case we're
going to try to follow the blue path now
so go ahead and save that and i will
run it and hopefully i don't forget
to show what i'm supposed to show but i
probably will we'll see
so we'll go ahead and run that see how
we do hopefully we cross the street
let's see what happens
starts off okay still got that really
jaggedy mouse but that's okay
we'll also fix that today
okay so that looks actually uh pretty
good
um we didn't run into anything but at
least okay yes we are following
the blue path at least that seems to
have worked
so uh look both ways for you across the
street and hopefully
we can get back to our starting spot
cool the path is like so weird so
we'll i'm sure we will see it but it's
like it's so random
and that's part of what we're going to
try or the next thing i'm going to show
you guys
is sometimes it updates correctly but
then sometimes it'll the blue path will
actually be behind me
sometimes the blue path like won't
actually update all the way to the
character so we have to handle for that
i mean
there's so many like little things it's
it's a fun challenge
i guess it's a silver lining it makes it
interesting to make a
like an ai like this but it's there's a
lot of little stuff
so anyway let's hop over to sublime text
again let me get
rid of the command window and
um make some of the changes that we want
to make so first of all if for some
reason
like what happens sometimes is the
yellow path might reach the character
but the blue path it could be behind us
but also like i said a lot of times it
doesn't like fully update all the way to
the character where we're looking on the
minimap so we want to
um we want to handle for that as well so
the way i'm going to do that is with a
try and
accept this logic is probably going to
make some people angry
that's okay so anyway paste and pop this
over so
so now rather than just simply this was
what we had originally
now what we're going to do is we're
going to try that but if that does not
work
so if the path is behind us what we're
going to hit is a nand when we go to
attempt to
calculate the error so we'll hit an
error and then we'll just accept
and we'll say we'll just print this out
to console just so we know that it's
happening
and we'll attempt to follow the yellow
path
now sometimes that won't work um but
i'll explain that in a moment so let's
go ahead and save that we'll go ahead
and run and let's see if we can get back
to everything
cool cool come over here great
okay i think we'll be okay but yeah
sometimes that yellow path
over like overlaps the blue path
and before anybody asks no there is you
can't actually ouch
you can't nice actually that's perfect
uh
oh dear we're not getting hit very hard
sometimes you'll get hit so hard um that
maybe you'll wind up like
facing this way like let's say oh my
gosh can you guys stop i'm trying to
film a video
oh my god okay maybe i'll back up for a
second i don't know okay
so imagine we got hit by our car really
hard and we're like looking this way
well if we go to run it he'll walk
forward but that's it because he's going
to press the key
the key button but we'll hit an error so
i'm just going to stop that
so we hit that nan so what should we do
in a scenario like that
right like the ai needs to figure out
how to write how to write itself
so the way that we can handle for that
is
let's bring back sublime text cool
and as you might guess
try and accept
like i said i'm sure there's a better
way if you want to like hopefully i'll
put it up on github and if someone has
better logic
um have at it this is what we did so
essentially this was our this is the
original or the code that we just ran
but if this fails so notice that we're
passing mini minimap
if this fails let's just do this exact
same thing so
we could probably at least condense the
code
in a few ways but basically we're doing
the same thing we're just going to use
the
full mini-map so let's go ahead and save
that and let's see
um this one's looking pretty goofy
i don't know if this is actually going
to work but let's we'll just see we'll
see what happens
so uh let's get everything
set up we'll leave sublime text bring
back the command prompt
run the script and let's see what
happens i guess
oh actually oh it is fixing itself okay
cool i i didn't know if it would
actually be able to turn quickly enough
but it does
do we get stuck here maybe nope oh i
think we
i think we would have actually made it
we just ran out of frames but i think if
i just press the w key yeah we'll get
around it but there
are going to be times where we also get
stuck on like a little planter like this
and all that and
we'll i'll show you how to handle that
uh as well
um okay so so it looks like that kind of
like zoom out logic
uh worked acceptably
so let's go back to our little starting
spot here
i really okay so here's an example uh
where
we will likely have to zoom out to find
the path as well so even though
we're pointed in the right direction i
believe uh it's zoomed out so far
uh like if you can see the little dotted
lines don't come all the way to the
character
so our initial really zoomed in view
like won't work and again this is just
one of those examples where
it's just really weird and sometimes the
blue path will do that but the yellow
path won't or vice versa but we're
trying to follow the blue path so
just take take note of that it's just
it's just kind of weird so
okay so that's our logic there the other
thing that i wanted to fix
uh was the mouse because the mouse
movement while it is functional
i find it to be very annoying so so
there's a
there's a few ways i'm only going to
show you the kind of two
major ways that i went about solving
this but essentially
what makes it jaggedy is instantly
moving
a lot of pixels so ideally
you would want to iterate and move like
one or two
something pixels at a time so uh so
first off
let me copy that and
don't forget to bring back sublime
and what we want to do is when we get
this error so rather than
doing this essentially we're just moving
in the
the amount of the error times three we
don't really want to do that
so instead we're going to iterate over
that movement and just
move that basically move some amount
basically and i just kept kind of kept
changing various versions
so so at least the negative one was used
to like
flip the sign so in this case i'm just
doing error over
absolute error essentially to to
to flip the sign i i messed with this so
many times that i
i can almost guarantee that somebody's
going to post a comment and be like you
idiot
you would just do this and it would be
super simple i recognize that
like i said i spent way too long this
isn't what i ended up with either but i
believe
what we do end up with uses the same
yeah the same logic so
sometimes i just get the spidey sense
that i've done something really dumb
and uh i just want to preempt it by
saying i'm sorry so
so anyway let's let's at least take a
look at what this looks like
and then i'll show you what i ended up
with and kind of explain so what i ended
up with is a little
a little more than this but essentially
all this is doing
is moving a smaller amount of pixels at
a time
so rather than moving the full error so
i'm also going i'll just add a slight
angle to it hopefully it'll find a path
it should fall back yeah full
wow it actually fell back okay
totally forgot to show the game when i
ran that so let's just rerun that one
more time
okay and i'm going to move the mouse a
little bit just to initially show the
wiggle
that we get okay so
this is pretty acceptable um i don't
like it because it does a lot of like
small
jaggedy movements still but it's way
better than what it was
that's for sure so that's a pretty good
adjustment now i just want to make one
more adjustment kind of show you what i
ended up with
and why but like i said i'm sure some
people can come up with a way better
solution
than what i've done just trying to get
this map to update cool
uh so let's bring back sublime text
not the command window i don't need that
and let me bring this over
[Music]
and we'll do
[Music]
this so essentially again you're just
trying to move in small amounts at a
time that's
that's kind of the name of the game but
this is what i ended with so the idea
here is to calculate a full range
and again i made so many like small
tweaks over time
that i remember one time i i wrote a lot
of code
to take like um so rather than
you know a dictionary is like a key that
references to a value
and then i change something in my script
and then i actually wrote code
that so basically my script was taking a
value and looking for a key
and then i changed some stuff in my
script and i was look i was using
the key looking for a value but i i
wrote some pretty complex code to do
that
and then when then it like clicked that
i was that you know you would just
reference it like you would any other
dictionary
um but yeah so those are mistakes that
get made so
i'm sure there's a better way to do this
but what i'm doing here
is um essentially we calculate the full
range that i want to take and i'm going
to iterate
through that full range as i iterate
through that full range um
as we make our way to halfway through
that full range i
move in plus plus equals one pixel at a
time so first we'll move one pixel
and then two and then three and then and
so on um
so it move it begins to move quicker and
then it slows down
so that's kind of more what you would
see when you're
actually you move a mouse right it's not
going to immediately move at top speed
it's going to speed up and then slow
down
as you reach like your objective so uh
just to show uh what's going on there
also the sleep
um i really just needed something to
slow it down so like without the sleep
it basically moves instantly
and that's no good this is not
functional it's just as functional as
doing
i don't know hello it's just pretty much
the same as doing that
i'm pretty sure just have something here
to slow it down slightly
that's all so let me go ahead and
remove sublime text add in the command
prompt
and run that i'm gonna again
move it a little bit
and you can see my beautiful work it's
just i don't it's like just slightly
smoother to me so i'm just going to bump
the mouse one more time
it just looks a little better to me
again you might disagree you might think
of a better way to do it but i
i like this way better so when the moves
are really small
it doesn't move like super fast but when
the move is big
it can get there relatively quickly it's
just a nice way to dynamically
impact i guess the fastest movement that
you might make
anyway so that's functional cool
so let me hopefully reset our path again
there we go so we still have a couple
more things that we need to
address let me bring back up sublime
text
and those two things are we quality
lifewise we need a way to
pause the script so the way that i'm
gonna do that is use the get
keys script that we used with
the pi gta series and that's actually a
really simple script
again there's i'll put a link to that
but also let me just pull it up in
sublime text here we go
so as you can see it literally it's just
looking to see what keys are pressed it
stores them into like a little list like
this
and what we're going to do is if any key
is
or if a specific key is pressed that
will
like we'll decide which key is the key
to pause but we want something to
to to be able to pause the script
because the script is taking control of
the mouse and that can get
very challenging because eventually we
want to run this on a while true
but then it becomes very hard to stop
the script so
uh so that's what we're going to use get
keys for so first of all just up
at the top we're going to from get keys
we're going to import key check
and then what i'm going to do is come
down to basically here right before
our loop and we're just going to say
paused
status and we'll say for now
that's false and then what we'll do
is essentially before we do
anything else we'd like to see so before
we waste any processing
uh we want to go ahead and make some
checks so i'm going to
copy this come down here
paste and we're gonna tab all this over
before i forget
boom cool so now what's what's happening
is pressed is that list of keys that are
that are currently being pressed
i'm choosing why because i don't think
it conflicts with any key
in the in the game that's it so
i think in gta we use t but i forget
what the t
key does in cyberpunk but it it's used
for something maybe phone
i can't remember anyway so if we
press y then we're just gonna flip the
bit so either it's going to be paused or
not
if we are paused then just print pause
sleep
and just wait until we're not paused
so if we're paused we'll do that
otherwise run as usual oh my gosh why
why why i just caught that we
e gross let's see if i can fix that i
thought i already fixed that
uh as the default but i guess i guess i
didn't
whoops hopefully i don't see any other
tabs
okay so we'll save that uh and let's go
ahead and run it
and see how we do we'll test that and
then if that works we can go ahead
and rather than range anything we can
just
make it a while true loop so let me move
this over
up on in uh if y impressed what did we
do
oh i thought we checked
i think that's it i think that's all
that error was but it's kind of weird
on indent does not match the outer i
believe the rest is fine i'm not sure
what i would be missing i think we're
good
please yes i really need a win today
okay oh let's go ahead and test a pause
okay so the key uh we i'll explain that
in a minute but we are paused
um and then we can unpause and we could
continue walking
i haven't really decided how best to
handle the key press essentially
all i want to use the pause for is
actually probably to stop the script i'm
pretty close to thinking you might as
well just break it if we press the key
but anyway so that appears to work but
the key does stay depressed you could
add some logic to
undepress it also just as a note so like
here for example the blue path begins
coming to towards the character but you
can see the yellow path doesn't for some
reason anyway weird stuff like that
happens i just wanted to say
also what okay okay in this case as you
can see
um the yellow path makes it all the way
to the character but not the blue path
so anyway a couple of quick examples of
why we needed the logic that we needed
um okay so
so now we've got the pausing capability
and finally we're going to top it all
off
with uh some motion detection so
strangely enough i have not run into a
car yet
i swear it happens all the time maybe
now is actually the time i'm actually
going to go ahead and pause the game
because i want that to hopefully stay
the case the other thing i could do
because the ai in this game is actually
so so stupid
i think what we'll do is i'll actually
block the road good they will not
drive around you it's it's
he's blocking me now okay okay thank you
idiot okay
so hopefully now that we've created a
traffic jam
um we will have some cars to walk into
although knowing my luck i will probably
walk perfectly in between them but
okay so so
so the thinking here is to use
motion detection and uh if
there isn't enough motion jump
and as funny as it is that's pretty much
always the solution also in this game
you have like a double jump
so we we could sorry buddy we could do
something like that as well
but for now i think we'll just do a
regular jump also like i think if you're
like
up against something a lot of games have
this like and then you jump you'll like
actually climb so if there's like a
fence in our way or something like that
we will be able to just climb
over it as well with with just by
pressing the space
key so that's what we're going to do
now so let me bring back sublime text i
think i've done good
enough i've made one mistake bringing up
sublime text hopefully
hopefully we're going to have a good
last time i didn't realize that i hadn't
brought something up for like i don't
know 20 minutes
anyway so um
okay so we want to do motion detection
so the way that we're going to
essentially motion detection
is just a difference in pixels
so again just like everything i've done
here there's like a million ways to do
motion detection we're just going to
implement a really basic one and it will
hopefully be good enough
so the first thing we're going to use is
the deck from collection so from
collections import deck and
essentially what this does for us is
i'll just say
for now screens is a deck
and then we're going to specify a maxlen
of two
so a deck is like a container
that will have a maximum size and then
as new elements come in
old ones get removed so uh this is our
this is we're just going to store the
screens
in here and then we'll just compare
screens so one to the other one and then
measure how much change has happened
and that is motion detection
simple so uh so coming down
to our script here and in fact
uh i think we can we'll just call this
while true now
we don't really i think we're all set i
don't think we'll get in trouble
as long as we can press the y key so
so coming down here if we aren't paused
we grab the screen
uh we're going to use screen to do this
but one of the things we
we probably could do it with the full
screen it's just kind of silly
we don't need the full screen so um
after we
did chop uh slice for the mini map and
mini mini map
um i just resized the screen we we could
um you could resize first and then slice
the maps
um i just didn't feel like having to
come up with the new values
so this is what i did so then
all we need to do now that we have the
two screens is we just compare the two
screens and again
essentially i'll just paste this in
first actually
essentially what um
what motion detection is is pretty much
this line but we're gonna we're gonna do
a few other things
generally you'll do this on grayscale
but if you're gonna do anything else we
could it
again we could change the orders i just
literally built this
and went with whatever worked
immediately but you could
do the diff on the gray and then blur
and then anyway
it doesn't really matter the order but
essentially
it is it's just doing an absolute
difference between
two frames and that will give you some
degree of motion
but we do add in a couple of other
things here so i
think i think i'll just paste it all in
and then we'll
kind of describe what's going on so
paste
and again this this is just kind of like
your garden variety
motion detection so we grab the
difference we're going to grayscale the
difference
blur it a little bit and then threshold
and
this way we only will have um
either black or white pixels there will
be nothing in between
so the diff is quite literally going to
be a scalar difference
but what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate that difference we're
going to grayscale it
add a little bit of a blur and then
threshold it and then in this case what
we're doing
is we're going to just calculate um
again using that arguer uh how many
pixels are 255 so the difference will be
a um a non-zero so above zero
and then we're going to threshold so if
the movement if the color change is
more than 50 essentially
then it will become 255
after we do the threshold so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take those movements and did we
um i don't think i have the movements
here
i think i think that's another deck yeah
okay i added one more thing
so essentially you could do it frame by
frame but what i ended up finding
was you pro like some frames for
whatever reason you just won't get that
much
detected movement even when you are
moving and even that after i made this
change
it still happened but it was a little
better worst case scenario you walk down
a path and you jump
right it's it's not terrible but i mean
i'd
i'd rather not jump everywhere but it's
not the end of the world if you do but
um
so what i want to do is come up to
besides screens we're going to say
movements and that'll be a deck of
length 10. you could change this you
tweak this i just
i just honestly took guesses and it
worked pretty fine
out of the box so coming back down uh
so yeah we append the movement count
there and then we just calculate the
average
and then i'm just printing it out and i
just wanted to print it out before i
came up with what
should our threshold for jumping be
um we are going to show it so you can
see it it may come up the first time i
might have to make some changes in
obs so we can see it but show the
movement detection so we can actually
see the threshold movement
and then if the movement average is less
than ten thousand
go ahead and you know press the space
space bar
so i think that's everything um we're
going to see we just change
added quite a bit so it's possible i
forgot something but let's get the
command window
come over to here and
there's like totally a path there i'm
gonna be so angry if we go between like
that brown car and that
little green car
let's see what happens also i'm curious
if we'll see
the uh other window i don't even see it
i'm not sure where it is
anyway we'll i'll i'll show oh yeah come
on get stuck
also we're not did i not i must not have
saved because we're totally stuck he's
not jumping
what is happening i'm actually kind of
confused i think i think the script just
like broke maybe
very okay we definitely did not save
so i'm gonna try one more time
not sure where anybody went
so you can see the movement averages at
least they're quite high like when
you're normally moving
and then hopefully we'll slow down
enough we got close not quite because
there we go so now we jumped over the
truck or whatever that was the suv
can't convert so it looks like we're
hitting some fail safe still working
though
hopefully we'll get over this car
somehow i guess if maybe we need to just
get back on our path because we are off
that path just slightly
there we go and we are on our way
uh i'm not sure if you can see i'm not
sure what you can see to be honest so
can you see that other
no so you can't see for some reason the
movement detection
i do kind of want to show that i think
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pause see if i can get away with this
i want you to see
[Music]
let's see if i can pull this up okay so
i've got the movement
uh or the motion detection down in the
lower
right i think i'm showing everything i
should show so we're just still on our
way
um and i mean everything that looks to
be going well
um so as you can see we're kind of
coming we're i think we're approaching i
forget exactly where the spot is that
we're supposed to go
so it got kind of dark here so like i
said like sometimes you're just going to
jump
i'm not really sure how i want to handle
for that yet
but we are making our way slowly but
surely to something going on over here
so eventually we want to get here
there's baddies here and we want to
handle the bad guys
uh right now we've got nothing and we're
probably going to die so let me just get
out of here
hello friends good day ouch please stop
no
not okay we died
[Music]
okay one more run let's see how
that works hopefully we'll get
everything to pop up at the same time
i think we've got a pretty good handle
of like all the things i really wanted
to do if you go right in between those
cars i'd be very angry
yes anyway i think we've got a pretty
good
handling of like all the little things
that we want to achieve here
as far as following the path i i think
this will do a good enough job i think
we're still going to be able to get
stuck
on certain things and we'll just have to
kind of figure out how are we going to
get through
things as they come up but i think this
will probably work for
i don't know 90 95 of the time i'm not
really sure
um so now that we've actually made our
way to the enemies
uh the decision is what do we want to do
about it so i'm going to go ahead and
pause before we get there and end up
getting killed again
um so we've got lots of options
when we get to the enemies i haven't
totally decided if anybody wants to make
a
place of vote for i don't know a rifle
we have shotguns we've got sniper rifle
and then we have the mantis blades and
these are kind of fun
as well so how should we handle
these enemies do we handle them from
afar up close
uh we also could probably handle them
randomly so
you know you we could have something
that you know uses some sort of weapon
and then randomly switches weapons and
stuff like that there's all kinds of
stuff that we could definitely do
oh because this is paused we're if i do
this
interesting anyway there's all kinds of
things that we could do wow why does
that happen that happened a second ago
as well i don't know why when we pause
sometimes that all pops up
anyway um yeah so uh if you
if you have any interest on what exact
what weapon of choice you think we
should use
place your vote below otherwise
i think this is a good stopping point
we've been going for quite some time and
this is kind of where i left off i
couldn't really decide
how do i want to handle those guys so um
so yeah let me know below if you've got
questions comments concerns suggestions
let me know you think i'm stupid for my
mouse movement let me know
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you